In Chrome Dev Tools,
there are two records that you might see
relating to layers or
composite to layers.
The first one is Update Layer Tree,
which happens when Chrome's internal
engine, called Blink, figures out
what layers are needed for the page.
It looks at the styles of
the elements and tries to figure out
what order everything should be in and
how many layers it needs.
Composite Layers is the other
record where the browser is now
putting the page together
to send to the screen.
The more layers you have,
the more time will be spent in
layer management and compositing.
So there's a tradeoff between
reducing paint time, and
increasing layer management time.